on Kickstarter I do because it's funny
with Kickstarter that the campaign i did
was in 2010 and i've been the main thing
is all my backers and i thank them so
much for for supporting us as they see
me touring with this film you know and
they're waiting for their thank you
gifts and there's the whole kickstarter
backlash about people not delivering on
but it's more about the products like
the complaints more about you know the
technology technology products more than
film is where people are saying well
they're not giving what they promised
and the thing for me was the delays the
blu-rays that I thought those were going
to be quick and easy to do because I
thought I could offer them myself and
send them to the duplication house and I
didn't realize that you know you need
special delivery software and and how
expensive to actually you know have
people do it for you and how much it
actually costs to do a blu-ray license
to actually have a blu-ray be pressed
and everything so I didn't resource that
aspect of it which put me behind and I
think that's the
the kind of dilemma if you with my
backers is they see me having this
finished thing but I'm not giving them
the finished thing you know and so I've
always said to them there's always a
download link if you ever want to see it
online you're welcome to of the actual
physical blu-ray it's you know I have to
create all the special features for it
still I have to find a vendor to find
the cheapest one because right now you
know they're on five thousand dollars to
press a thousand so it's you know you're
like shopping around to find out which
one is the who's going to cut you the
best deal and that takes time because
everyone's you know just you know give
you price quotes you're trying to
negotiate and stuff so that's the part
where you feel like I need to check in
and let them know but you know other
than that it's something where it's you
know too much too many updates they get
sick because they're like okay I I get
it you're on Twitter you already tweeted
about anyways you know what I mean so
that's the one thing it's just I want to
be able to deliver and if I ever did it
again it's setting expectations about
that more
you